same thing goes for you actually as well
you can unmute yourself and ask a
question
uh whenever you'd like so so you know
exploring
a
landslide of questions
uh all right hi everyone uh
i'm cindy
uh so today i'm gonna talk about um
approximate message passing algorithms
uh generally
uh you guys can hear me with like the
mask and the microphone right
cool
um so what i'm gonna uh do today uh in
the lecture i'm gonna roughly um follow
along uh a tutorial article that um
i just wrote with my my co-authors
oliver fang
ramji venkata ramadan and richard
samworth all from the university of
cambridge
um
so uh
you know today when when we go through
uh what what what i'm going over some of
the math and these sorts of things i'm
going to try to give kind of heuristic
proofs or some intuition for some of the
mathematical aspects of the approximate
message packing algorithms
and it won't be rigorous at all so um
you know if you want to see the the
rigorous side of things it's all there
in uh the tutorial article that's like a
hundred or something pages so whatever i
do today you know if you want to to
really see the the real deal
um
that's the the place to go
okay so um
just to begin with uh what is
approximate message passing or what do
these
algorithms mean for us so in short um
approximate message passing or amp is a
class of iterative algorithms um they
can be used for a number of things but
probably most uh
relevant to this audience is that they
can be used for establishing
computational limits of statistical
estimation problems
and so um
that's what we're going to talk to talk
about for the the first half of um my my
talk today is just
um how can we you know understand
computational limits through approximate
message passing
um so some you know of the statistical
estimation problems that uh amp has been
used to study are things like high
dimensional linear regression or
compressed sensing this is sort of the
original problem
it was studied for phase retrieval and
other generalized linear models and then
also low rank matrix estimation and so
we're going to touch on
each of these sorts of estimation
problems throughout the talk
okay so um the reason that uh you know
two of the the reasons that we like a
and p
um two of the attractive features that
kind of make this uh useful is um
anti-algorithms
easily use uh
prior information on the signal so it's
easy to kind of tailor the algorithms to
exploit whatever knowledge you have
about the signal so i'm thinking things
like you know
in low rank matrix estimation right
you might know that the the signal
generating the low low uh rank matrix is
actually sparse and so it's easy within
the amp algorithms to
exploit that information
um
the other nice thing about amp
algorithms is that they have uh precise
asymptotic
uh performance guarantees uh in the form
of like the statistical
characterizations of the iterates of the
algorithm
and in particular um the asymptotics
that they study are is
this uh regime where you know if we have
um n as our sample size and d is uh you
know the dimension of the problem then
uh both of these parameters are growing
um in such a way that their their ratio
uh approaches some constant value
right so this is the asymptotic regime
i'm going to be thinking about during
the you know next two hours of the
lecture
and so um what do i do with with amp um
right well the point three is what we're
going to to mostly focus on but um
i know there's a lot of nice things so
uh michael celantano's work uh shows
that you can use amp to obtain lower
bounds on estimation error first order
methods
it also gives you a precise asymptotics
for various statistical estimators which
is
something that i'm hoping to get to in
the second half of the talk
and then um as i mentioned in some
problems it helps us understand
statistical computational gaps and so um
this is this third point is what we're
going to focus on now
okay so um
uh so normally when you know uh you
start reading papers on uh approximate
message passing
um
the ideas are originally uh presented
through some derivation from a belief
propagation algorithm so the idea is you
have a problem like compressed sensing
uh you write down a factor graph
representation of the problem you write
down a belief propagation over that
factor graph and then you make some
approximations and sort of outputs the
the amp algorithm and so the papers i've
cited here have given those uh belief
propagation type derivations um for a p
algorithms for the the various problems
and so um while you know that sort of
derivation from belief propagation uh
can be
useful um and you know when you're doing
analysis of the algorithms and it can be
insightful it's not strictly necessary
um
if we just want to understand
sort of uh how to look at phase
transitions or how to look at these
sort of asymptotic statistical
guarantees for the algorithms so instead
of actually deriving a and p from
uh the belief propagation like the these
works have done i'm going to take sort
of a different approach which is that
i'm just going to write out a standard
amp recursion that's not associated with
any sort of
statistical estimation problem
it's basically just a recursion on
gaussian matrices
and then we're going to to study the
statistical properties of the simple
recursion and then show how all these
other
problems kind of just you can reduce
those amp algorithms back to the the
standard uh sort of simple uh basic amp
recursion so the idea is i'm going to
give sort of a basic
uh amp and then from that we'll build
until we get uh all of these these sorts
of specialized amps for various problems
okay so uh as i mentioned right the
starting point of our development
uh for today is going to be just an
abstract amp recursion that
is not related to any specific
estimation problem
and then what we're going to see um
is that the empirical distribution of uh
the the coordinates of
each iterate of this like basic amp is
going to be approximately gaussian and
then the the properties of that gaussian
are going to be determined by a state
evolution and so the idea is if we can
kind of understand the statistical
properties of the really vanilla amp
algorithm then when we look at these
more complicated amp algorithms we'll
just kind of reduce it back to this this
vanilla um
this vanilla result
okay so um the outline for the talk i'm
going to start by just giving the
standard a and p
this is going to be a
i'll start with a symmetric
recursion so we're going to look at
symmetric gaussian random matrices
um
are goe matrices so
uh in the first part of the top every w
matrix is going to be a
an m by n matrix
uh that's symmetric
so uh the the elements above the
diagonal um are going to be
uh normal with uh variance one over n
and then um on the diagonal uh
also normal but but with a different
variance right so this is just a
symmetric gaussian matrix
then we're going to look at the high
dimensional um properties
of the the simple recursion using the
state evolution
and then at the end we'll connect
the standard amp to low rig matrix
estimation and then discuss some uh
further extensions and generalizations
okay
so um here's the the basic
uh a p algorithm that that i want to
study
um so the idea is uh the following
um so we're gonna initialize our
algorithm uh with some
deterministic or random vector uh h0
so h is a length n vector
and this vector is going to be
independent of my goe matrix w right so
now i have i have two objects i have my
matrix w which is my symmetric gaussian
matrix and then i have an initialization
uh that's a vector independent of it
and so um in the standard amp algorithm
what we're going to do is we're just
going to
you know sort of recursively define a
sequence of iterates
h1 through uh you know ht let's say
um that are defined in the the following
way so uh you know h t plus one
uh is uh the sum of a matrix um vector
product right where we have our g o e
matrix uh and then our vector is going
to be
some function acting on the previous
iterate
and then we're going to to correct that
with
another term that's the product of a
scalar
value lambda and then um my my previous
sort of uh function acting on the the um
iterate just before
so in in this um recursion right what do
we have
so uh i have some function here f t
that um i'm thinking about this as being
a scalar function that acts coordinate
wise on its vector input
right and i'm just going to assume that
it's just some lipschitz function right
now right
um and then i have a scalar term that's
just defined in terms of the average of
the the derivatives of this this
lipschitz function right
so at this point
i'm not thinking about any specific
estimation problem i'm just thinking
about um
a recursion on
gaussian matrices
okay
all right so what i'd like to do is you
know can we can we understand the
properties the statistical properties of
uh this this vanilla amp right
h
h uh so h
i'm thinking of this as a
recursion right so these are vectors uh
that are computed this way so
so so ft is a scalar function so you
apply coordinate wires yeah
okay and here you apply to each uh
okay here you just apply it to each
coordinate and
you just sum up
right yeah so the scalar right
vector vector matrix
okay
okay so the the first question is right
can can we say anything about the the
statistic
statistical properties of this um
iteration and
it turns out that we we can
and so um the way that we do that is
through uh something referred to as a
state evolution right and so
uh the state of illusion
um is just going to be a deterministic
recursion that actually tells us
something about the performance or the
the sort of properties of the standard
amp right so what i'm going to do is
define the the
state evolution and then we'll get to
the the sort of theoretical guarantees
and so um the state of elusion looks
like uh the following so the first thing
we do is we we set our our tau uh one
squared
as um a limit based on our
initialization so
uh our initialization right is this h0
we assumed it was independent of the the
matrix and so now i i initialize with um
some limiting value of that that
what's this initialization in the limit
what are you taking the limit over oh
sorry this is the parameter n right so i
have my vectors h0 these are linked in
vectors my matrix is an n by n
uh
matrix so
this is a the the problem size right
okay and so um one of the things i'm
going to do is just assume that this
limit exists so nothing crazy is
happening there
and then um i i have another recursion
now right that's just um
a deterministic
uh
scalar recursion based on
uh this function that i'm using in my my
standard amp and then um some
independent gaussians
so
h naught is random and i just touch i
think of cow is random whereas
this limiter
converges with hyperability to for
converges to a number
yeah so this is a deterministic so
yeah so you can think of i mean
uh h0 can be random or deterministic i
mean i think it's easiest if we just you
know you can think of it as like a
vector with iid elements or something
tell t plus 1 squared
is equal to the expectation
of our function that we use in the
recursion
that takes as input tau t so the
previous
value and
multiplying a gaussian random variable
so expectation with respect to the
gaussian
okay
okay so um
now uh with this uh we're ready to give
the main theoretical results and um um
before i do that i'm going to define
something called a pseudo lipschitz
function because the theoretical results
are
um
given in terms of of uh such functions
so a pseudo lipschitz function is just a
generalization of the notion of ellipses
function right so i'm going to say a
function
uh
psi is in uh pseudo ellipses of order k
with a constant c if this property holds
so
essentially a function uh is
lipschitz if it grows like you know
uh
some constant times x to the k
is pseudo lipschitz if it grows like
that okay
so then um
the theory is the following so if we
assume that our matrix is goe so
symmetric gaussian right independent of
our initialization
um we also need to assume that the
empirical distribution of our
initialization uh as input to our
function f o converges so this is just
so that my
first tau one uh
over here is well defined right
um i also need some bounded moments on
uh this condition
and then uh with some regularity
conditions on ft beyond just the
lipschitz property but are unimportant
um
what what we see is the the following um
we get our main theoretical result so
this says
uh for any pseudo-lipschitz function psi
of order k
for every iteration of our algorithm
we get the the following so
uh the average of
uh psi acting
on the elements of the iterates
converges to
a deterministic limit
that's an expectation with respect to
these towels which are determined by the
state evolution
right so this is the the tau t just from
state evolution
this is just you know
a
an independent gaussian random variable
right so basically what this tells us is
you know
if we have a pseudo lipschitz function
that we're interested in
then we can uh determine the high
dimensional properties of the iterates
of the amp algorithm
based on these state evolution values
right so as an example right we might
consider something like
the function
uh
psi of x equals x squared right
in which case this result tells us that
uh
the limit
of
the two norm of our iterates at time t
converges to
t squared which is the value given by
state evolution
sorry yes
yeah uh
all right
thanks
okay
okay
so um
okay so basically uh the way we should
think about is that
we can imagine that uh
after the t steps of the pollution this
is more or less like a
normal speed that uh
exactly so uh my first remark is kind of
to this point so
uh there's a lot of different notions of
convergence that we can kind of show so
here
uh whoa
i'm sorry
um
i should have closed my eye
okay so
okay so what we what what i presented
there was um
in terms of of almost sure convergence
so the the first thing i wanted to
mention is we can kind of strengthen the
convergence to complete convergence uh
automatically which
uh if you're not familiar with complete
convergence it's not uh particularly
important but somehow it seems to be the
correct notion of convergence we're
using here
um
and it just says that you know we have a
sequence x n that converges completely
to some deterministic value x
if uh
y n
which is any sequence
such that x n is equal to y and n
distribution for all n
uh converges almost surely to x
and so then once
you've shown this complete convergence
uh what you get is actually a uniform
convergence over pseudo lipschitz
function so instead of you know for
every pseudo lipschitz function you can
uh show the convergence uniformly
um from which you can actually get a
result about um the empirical
distribution of the elements so this is
kind of what i think you were getting at
earlier
the kind of easier way to think about
these convergence is not through the
pseudo-lipschitz functions but
or i think at least
but um and through statements about
empirical distributions of the elements
so we have a vector ht and what we've
shown is that the empirical
distributions of its elements
uh converges completely in uh w2
to um a mean zero gaussian with variance
determined by the the state evolution so
what you can kind of think of then is
that you know this vector h t for my
standard amp
has elements
uh as if
you know they were drawn from this this
gaussian distribution right so you know
empirical distribution of the elements
i'm just thinking about like the
histogram of the elements it's going to
look as if it's a histogram
uh
how this
is formatting on me sorry
it's going to look as if it's a
histogram of of you know gaussian draw
this particular thing
maybe the first element like the odd
elements being correlated with the even
element that just came before them but
the globally the histogram would look
like
uh
yes i think that
that's correct right so
uh you know all we can prove is is
exactly the statement
okay
um
so a second remark is that you know
rule
um
that you cannot you can prove that if
you fix anything
coordinates then
the joint technical distribution of any
fixed k coordinates converges to the
problem
and this the reason is that you know by
just the reach of each of them the
vector is exchangeable
yes
sometimes you really could basically
imagine that
if you if you imagine that
at stage t it's an iid gaussian
distribution with a standard deviation
tau t you would not be what
you'd expect that any predictions you
made under these assumptions
the pledge question that you cannot make
is saying something like the first card
in stage
that or a sublinear fraction of
correlates can be equal to achieve that
random subliminal
okay
uh
the second point uh i wanted to make is
that um we can also extend the the
results to a joint distribution over the
the um
iterates of the amp algorithm so
uh you know before right we were looking
at some pseudo lipschitz function just
acting on the elements of ht my my teeth
uh sort of uh iterate in in my amp but
in fact you know we can take a pseudo
ellipse its function that you know takes
t inputs right and um get a a result
here right and so the the difference now
is you know
uh on the right hand side this is still
a deterministic limiting value
uh that depends on the state evolution
but now we have to sort of uh
define the covariance structure of these
these gaussian
matrices
and uh it's not the covariance structure
isn't um
important but the the short sort of
takeaway is that it's also determined by
the state evolution as as well so
this covariance matrix of these limiting
gaussians
is also defined recursively the
covariance matrix at time t
uh is the the matrix that adds a a row
and a column to the the covariance
matrix at times t minus one
um where these these values
again are determined by um something
that looks like the
the state evolution the actual values
are not important but the the point is
that you know we can characterize the
joint distribution of the iterates of
the a and p as well
okay so um
what i want to do is try to uh give a
sketch
um of the proof so again um
the proof is is pretty technical it's an
induction on the iteration number so
we aren't going to go through the whole
thing but i want to try to give kind of
a high level sketch so you can see where
um
you know these
uh these values are coming from
so um
to do this i'm going to start with uh
just the first iterate so um
you remember uh let's see here oh i can
do this okay
so um when we looked at our amp
algorithm
we had the h1 uh so this is you know the
the t equals one iterate it equals
w our goe matrix
times our function f zero
acting on our initialization
minus a scalar term times now a negative
1 term here but
when i define this algorithm i i'm
assuming that negative indices
equal zero so this term just this uh
drops away so in short what i have is
for my first iterate um it's just going
to be the product
of a matrix
uh with a vector
and um we know that these two are
independent right we assume that our
initialization was independent of the
the matrix w so we can characterize this
uh
the statistical properties of this
exactly right
so in particular
if we
think conditional
on h0
since h0 is independent
of w
uh we have the the following
right w times
of zero of h0 is just going to be
uh normal right because w is normal and
now conditional on h0 we have a
deterministic vector there right
where the mean is zero
and uh the variance is
almost
uh
the identity
um but there's one additional term that
just comes from
okay so
uh
right so what what's the the takeaway
here right so um when we look at this
distribution okay so this is uh this is
a a deterministic value because we're
thinking conditional on our
initialization so we have um some value
times the identity and then we have a
kind of rank one
uh perturbation to that identity
covariance that just comes from the fact
that our wmh is symmetric
and so um
if we want to analyze sort of the
asymptotic properties of this right
where we're in this asymptotic setting
where n
is going to infinity then we can just
study these these two terms
right and so um it turns out that
you know the first term just converges
to tau 1 squared by assumption right so
this term here
1 over n
f 0 h 0
squared
uh converges to tau 1 squared maybe i
shouldn't use arrows as my bullets
there
right so this converges to
tau 1 squared my state evolution value
by assumption
and then this
order 1 term or sorry this rank 1 term
is just negligible and the the limit
right so this kind of goes away so again
we we're just going to kind of ignore
that so what we've shown right is uh you
know
uh conditional on our our initialization
then we have that h1
uh is
like normal zero uh
with with this sort of um
variance right with the variance given
by tau one squared so what we've shown
right is sort of kind of motivating this
this first statement uh
that we have uh up here
okay so
the reason that was easy was because uh
this term kind of dropped out so we just
had our matrix vector multiplication
right and it was also easy because uh
the vector we were multiplying by the
matrix these guys were independent right
the w was assumed to be independent of
my initialization h0
but what happens is that um you know
if we look at h2
right h2 is going to be w times f1 of h1
right and we're no longer going to have
that independence because h1 was
constructed by w2
right so when we sort of
uh this this
notion this step zero sort of uh proof
doesn't doesn't continue
but
on the um vector and just
look at the randomness orthogonal
uh
yes so this is essentially what we do
okay
so um
let's look at the induction step right
so okay what do we have when we have the
the induction step so um we're looking
at ht plus one
equals again our matrix
multiplied by ft acting on ht minus our
scalar value determined by the
derivatives
and
uh the the the lag term right
okay
so um
all right so how what are we going to do
right uh so essentially the the idea is
is kind of what uh was mentioned what
we'd like to do is sort of
uh
decompose this matrix
w uh along a basis
uh that's sort of you know determined by
the previous iterations of the algorithm
so what i'm going to do is define a
sigma algebra algebra
generated by h1 through ht the previous
of iterates
and then look at the conditional
distribution of w given uh that sigma
algebra right so what's the distribution
of w now that we've seen
the the values before
and um it turns out that this is kind of
the trick that allows us to
analyze the the recursion right and so
um
this is a an idea that goes back to uh
bolt housing originally and then um
by adi and montanari um
did in their their original sort of 2011
proof
but um the idea is uh the following so
um if we define
okay our
uh sigma algebra is st
it's going to be the sigma algebra
generated by
h1
up through ht
right so these are this is the sigma
algebra generated by the first uh t
iterates i probably should put the the
initialization in there as well but
fine then um what i'm going to do is
decompose
w uh
with respect to this the sigma algebra
so i want to decompose
my matrix w
uh as follows so
um what i want to show is that
conditional on
the the
previous outputs of my my algorithm
my matrix w has the following um
distribution so
it's equal to
a projection
onto that sigma algebra right so the
conditional distribution of w onto
my condition sigma algebra plus um a
projection uh perpendicular to
the the sigma algebra so here um
what am i saying so
i'm thinking of pt
equals
orthogonal
projection
onto the span
of
uh
h0 through ht
and then
this
and pt perp is just uh
i minus that
okay so this is this is just uh
true for for
uh any matrix right so what we're
conditioning on and short is sort of
linear constraints on that matrix so
then we can decompose that into a part
uh
sort of uh orthogonal to those
constraints and then
deterministic
uh with respect to those constraints
yes
yeah so the m0s instead of
yeah
so this should actually be a
projection projecting onto
uh
f0h0
sorry
[Music]
okay
okay and so then um the the kind of uh
key part of this for uh
[Music]
for us is that um since you know our
matrix w is a goe matrix right it's um
symmetric gaussian
it's also rotationally invariant so what
that gives us is that uh you know what
we can do
is replace
uh the random piece that comes from the
projection
uh with a a new
matrix w hat where
you know
or w tilde sorry w tilde is equal in
distribution to my original uh w but
it's independent of
my conditioning sigma algebra
and so um
this is kind of the the key step right
is that here
you know we use the rotational
invariance of the the gaussians
to um
you know now represent my my random
matrix w as a deterministic part and
then
a part uh independent of my conditioning
sigma algebra
right um
and you know that that that's the
projection outside of the sigma algebra
as well
okay so um
let's see
okay so what does this actually give us
right so um what we've shown right is we
have a representation for my my
matrix w equal and distribution
conditional on um my iterates up to time
t
uh that's a deterministic piece
uh plus a projection
where the matrix and the prediction is
is
independent
so then um this allows us to
consider my
uh
my iterate at time t plus one also sort
of conditional on the previous iterates
right
so what i have here right is if we look
at you know
this sort of representation here now
what i'm going to do is is plug in
this
for the the w here right so what i get
is that my h t plus one is equal in
distribution to
uh
a deterministic piece
multiplying by
f
fthg
my scalar
correction term
uh plus my projection term
[Music]
okay
so um okay so so
this is sort of nice right because what
ends up happening is you know when we
look at this what we see is that this
whole part up here is measurable with
respect to my
sigma field
right so this is this is all you know
conditional on the previous iterates
this is all
deterministic right
and then uh the part that's that's
random right it's random but it's
independent of the
everything we've seen before right so we
have a new
goe matrix here that's independent of
everything else and so um
this is kind of the the you can kind of
see where we're going here right so i'm
going to argue inductively right that
that this deterministic piece right this
is just going to be somehow gaussian
that's the the induction assumption and
then we get a new piece that's the new
independent gaussian and so we can kind
of add up all those gaussians and as
long as we track the variance
uh we can we can see what happens
okay
and so um in short you know this is this
is uh
you know a really uh sort of long proof
but the idea is that you know you you
look at that deterministic piece and
kind of um
look at its structure
and you find that that it looks
something like
uh the following what you have is a sum
of uh the previous iterates
right so this is um
a sum of my h i where i goes from one to
t so the previous iterates of the
algorithm
combined with some alpha eyes
whose value i i won't state but but
they're there
we get a new piece like this is our
perpendicular piece that's
from a new gaussian vector and then we
get some
deviation term
right so that the idea is you know you
can show that that this sort of
uh
representation that comes from our
distribution our distributional
properties of our our goe matrix gives
us this form
right and what what do we have well what
we're going to argue is you know these
are gaussian by induction
all right we already showed the step
zero gave the the gaussian for h naught
um this is going to be an independent
gaussian piece
right that comes from our w tilde up
there so this
is the the part you know
outside of the previous iterates but
it's new independent gaussian and then
this is going to be something that's
just negligible so you know i can show
something like
the squared norm of this guy goes to
zero
okay so uh the basic you know the the
the sort of technical part right is
actually figuring out like what what
these guys are so these are these are
random but what you can prove is that
they have deterministic limits and the
values of the those deterministic limits
are given by the state evolution right
so then what you end up with right as a
sum of
of gaussians where you know
the components um summing the gaussians
you get an independent gaussian piece
and this is also something we can
determine by the state evolution and
then there's some deviation term that
you have to argue doesn't
matter asymptotically but the the the
takeaway right is that this essentially
gives you
uh what you want once you take kind of
careful
uh record keeping of of you know
all of these terms you get this this
sort of
one hd minus one exactly cancels
right so what ends up happening right is
you get some things
um
[Music]
up here that are you know that go into
kind of the gaussian part and you get
some things that are non-gaussian and
then this correction term the unsoccer
correction term is chosen so that it
asymptotically sort of cancels out those
non-gaussian pieces
uh so it's it's
you know essentially this choice here
that gives you this going to zero
uh that ensures that we we continue
getting the gaussian as we iterate that
algorithm
um right
and let me see if there's anything else
uh i want to to say about that and it's
it's actually it's kind of like you can
you know if you go under the proof you
can see well why this is right it's
signs lima
say it again sorry
uh no these are actually highs
there's kind of a lot of steps between
like here
and here so
uh
you do some taylor approximation this is
the linear contribution from the
derivatives
matrix
will be a combination of right-hand
components and the random components
will contain the f and the h's
turns out that all the ones that contain
that are cancelled by the oscillators
the others
other proportions
i mean yeah it's like say
there there are the s somewhere in here
but it's you know it either gets
subsumed here or the coefficient's got a
zero or something so
it's a i mean
yeah
i don't know the proof is
uh really long right so uh you know it's
like
quite a mess but this is the this is i'm
you know i'm hoping this is insightful
um some sort of short pickle
okay so i was you know okay so what are
what are what are we um
what are we doing right so i wanted to
give some kind of high-level idea of
about why we can take a simple iteration
like that and you know say anything at
all about the the statistical uh
components
but you know that iteration i was
looking at it wasn't actually
doing anything right it wasn't like
solving any problem all i was trying to
convince you of is that if we just
you know have sort of a matrix vector
multiplication that happens in this way
then we can say something statistically
rigorous about uh
you know the the output and so um what
i'd like to do now is try to connect
uh
this standard amp to an actual problem
and the actual problem i'm going to look
at
is uh this problem of rank one matrix
estimation
and so um the rank one matrix estimation
problem is the the following so i i'm
going to imagine i have a model um so i
have some data matrix a that i see
that i'm modeling as uh the sum of a
rank one piece determined by
some signal vector v here
and a goe matrix so here w is my goe
matrix as before
right
my my signal sort of is is defined by
my
parameter theta that just
determines the signal to noise ratio in
the problem right um and also my vector
uh
v here which i'm thinking is again some
random or deterministic vector that's
going to be independent of w
that's actually the the signal giving
the rank one piece and my rank one
matrix estimation problem
right and so the idea right is that that
we we see a
what i'm going to assume is that my
elements of v are
jumps like this sorry my elements of v
are iid
according to some distribution pv
right and then sorry that's supposed to
be if i have a capital v
uh distribution as pv then
it has
so yeah
at capital b but
okay so it's clear
we're good okay
all right so i i have a i want to
determine b for b
geez
right
okay
so um the first thing i'm going to do
right is uh i want to do this by using
an amp algorithm so um
how do i do this right so what i'm going
to do is i'm going to try to use
our standard
amp recursion that we looked at before
but
i want to make it useful and so you know
when we looked at the standard recursion
it was a recursion with a
matrix w
but now this matrix is my noise matrix
and i don't see it so i'm just going to
write the same amp algorithm that i was
looking at earlier but
now
i'm going to replace that matrix w that
we don't know
with my matrix a that's the data matrix
from the problem
right okay so this is the same recursion
i was looking at earlier
but now
you know
instead of calling them ages i've called
them x just to recall that now i have my
data matrix there and not my my goe
matrix
and so um
what we're going to do is is you know
try to appeal to
my standard amp results
in order to say something smart about
the distributional properties of this
recursion so the first thing i'm going
to do is plug in
my my a so
since we know a equals
theta over n vv transpose
plus w
right
uh
then what do we have well we get that my
recursion looks like the following we
get theta over n v
an inner product between v
and
ft acting on
x t
plus
w times f t x t
minus lambda t
f t minus one x t minus one
okay and so um the the thing we we
notice right is that
so now after we plugged in my my model
and to uh the amp with with a replacing
w what what do we get out well we get
out you know uh a recursion that has
part of it which is just the standard
amp recursion we looked at before right
so this is you know sort of uh exactly
the standard amp
uh plus a shift term right so now
this is sort of like a shift
and so um
what we might want to do now is try to
see if we can kind of guess
the distributional properties of this
recursion based on our knowledge of you
know what happens with the standard
recursion right
so um
it turns out we can we can do that right
so uh you know how how do we do it well
this we can characterize we know you
know it's
uh looks gaussian with mean or with
variance determined by the state
evolution and then this is something
well you know this inner product we can
just appeal the like law of large
numbers and get
a concentration type thing there so
let's let's go through this um
there's one little caveat so
uh what i'm i'm going to do is i'm going
to cheat a little bit and so
let's cheat a little bit and assume uh
that i have an initialization for this
algorithm that's correlated with my true
signal
so
i'm going to assume an initialization uh
that looks like the following so in
practice right uh
well we will we'll talk about it but let
let me cheat for right now and say that
i can initialize with something
correlated with the the truth
um
so here i'm thinking of
uh z zero
being a vector
of gaussians
uh independent of v
my signal
okay
so if i do that if i cheat and i
initialize
correlated
with the the the truth um then i can uh
look at analyzing this so let's start in
the same way we did before right by just
looking at the
the first term so the t equals
zero case so if i look at the t equals
zero case like i did before then what we
see right is that this term is again
going to go away because my negative
indices are zero
so i just get something that looks like
uh
theta over n
v times
inner product v of 0 x 0
plus
w
f 0 x 0
right where uh sorry where again x0 i'm
thinking of as being correlated
a little bit with the the truth right
and so um
what we find right is you know uh we we
can sort of analyze this so
the first point is that by
law of large numbers
of large numbers uh you know assuming
that v is
iid pv
right
[Music]
what do we have this inner product
that converges to
an expectation right
so an expectation of v
plus 0 mu zero
right where v
is a random variable distributed as pv
[Music]
um and then again
you know
if
x0 is independent
of w
right then uh
w
of 0 0
is like
normal 0 1 over n
norm of f 0.
plus a delta term which you know
again this guy is uh
okay so
right so we look at our our x1
we um you know can kind of argue that
this guy is going to
to
concentrate on some deterministic
expectation
and you know this guy too this is the
same sort of analysis we did earlier
it's going to be
uh gaussian as well and so um
what do we sort of show
well um
okay what this gives us
right is a result like
the following um
okay so i guess i'll do one more step
which is you know uh
remind us that something like
this
will limit to something like
right and so uh putting those together
you know putting together
what have we found well we've shown that
x1 uh
will limit to something that looks like
the following where uh this
u1
is
this guy
and then uh our sigma one
is the square root of
f zero
squared
and so this is just putting these pieces
together right so
here you know we get that this
concentrates on this expectation so now
we have
uh x1 is equal to our true signal
uh plus you know
uh
there right
theta times uh the limiting expectation
right so this gives us the the first
term right where the the mu is is that
guy and then the second uh term just
comes from looking at at this which is
our gaussian piece right
okay so
uh you know what what we what we've
shown is is it's you know how you could
get something like this right of course
this isn't a
rigorous proof but you know you can take
these ideas and and sort of
uh get to to a statement of the the
following and um
you know if you if you go through sort
of an induction argument like we did
earlier
uh then
what you can show is that uh you know if
you uh assume that your uh
teeth iteration has this distribution
right so motivated by what we just
looked at for the first iteration
um then you can show that your t plus
one iteration
uh has this distribution where the the
mean and the the variance there are just
updated by
you know the the way that we kind of
motivated by looking at
different stuff right so
you know again right you have to
actually make the inductive argument but
it turns out that it works out just you
know kind of like what we did here we
see the same form when we update the mu
and the the sigma as we go
sorry so these guys should be
the t should be in the air right
okay
okay so um
okay so maybe
uh
since it's already
passed we'll like take a break now and
then i'll finish uh when we come back
still work
okay
okay are there any questions at this
point
all right so for the spike matrix
problem what would uh
be
yeah so uh we'll talk about it a little
bit more
when we come back from the break i
didn't
i thought i'd get through more so i
didn't have a good stopping point but
essentially what you do is um you know
you can look at something like this
right and uh if you know that my teeth
iteration has this sort of distribution
how
what do i what do i want right i want
this to be large
relative to this right so that i get
mostly signal and only a little bit of
noise and so
you can actually choose the f to
optimize that signal to noise ratio and
the f that optimizes that comes out to
be something that's uh proportional to
the conditional distribution
so this is something we'll talk about
uh yeah so um
yeah so
theoretically there's been a lot of
study of non-gaussian matrices so uh if
the
[Music]
yeah studied uh sub-gaussian design
matrices there's also been a line of
work um looking at rotationally
invariant matrices so this is like
orthogonal amp or vector approximate
message passing and show fan i just had
a recent paper along those lines um
there's also been some extension uh chin
and lamb
uh
updated the the original beyonce the
large and montenario results for sub
gaussian music so there's been a lot of
work in this area but it turns out if
you change the matrix uh things like the
state evolution and stuff have to change
a little bit too so the recursions are
slightly different but you can still get
the same
this might be addressed later but is
there like a natural multivector
generalization of this where
um
i guess you track the state of like
multiple vectors and
get some nice recursion that like what's
once you understand it yeah so yeah so i
mentioned you can okay so you can get an
asymmetric version so if your matrix w
is not
symmetric but you know just iod gaussian
and so then you get a two sequence
recursion and you can also extend that
to kind of matrix iterates
uh and it turns out that the extension
to the matrix iterates is useful because
you need it to prove things like
generalized versions of approximate
message passing so if you want amp to
solve like generalized linear models for
example
so there's an extension that has matrix
so is like is there any way to motivate
why uh this kind of uh iteration is
working is it trying to solve any like
fixed one problem or
trying to estimate things something like
that or like what on what kind of
problems the same algorithm before you
learn inclusion yeah so i mean it
uh it works well for problems where
you have like a planet solutions or
something like
uh the
you know literary matrix estimation
right you have that signal b that's
generating your dot negatives or
something like
uh high dimensional linear regression
where you know you have a signal x
that's
uh generating your your
very important um
what do you have in mind
no i don't know i'm just asking
i guess maybe like if
say a instead of a of x being uh
like
a random plus noise
it would be
you apply
some yeah i don't know
quadratic to
something plus so so the some of the the
the noise is not added in a linear way
to the
so some quadratic operator or something
like that
yeah
[Music]
so
like uh
yeah i don't know
i mean if you if you want to build in a
a quadratic model for a low-rank
estimation and yeah it ends up
you know being difficult to create the
non-trivial model but something that is
nonlinear is if you want to do tense or
low-rank tensor simulation
but you still have like an additive
noise it turns over
yeah the signal is like spike tensor so
but it's still linear and
you know it's ax then
for the
generated randomness
there but
approximation is possible by a lot of
demand as well
uh
yeah i i mean i'm i'm okay with that uh
refinement of i say that yeah
uh
yeah
even that is not the third one
because you can take f to be not settled
right i agree
or like if your signal has some
dependencies between the entries
okay so maybe we better take this yeah
yeah
we'll be back here